Steve at the lass at the end of the last
section we were talking did bit about
the servants and how they relate to the
fate of Israel and who the agents of
Redemption are and this very uneasy
relationship or at least unclear
relationship between what God's role in
redemption is and what the role of the
community is and we've looked at
throughout the book at a lot of these
divine agents including various kinds of
servants Israel itself Jerusalem City as
a servant various individuals unnamed
one of the most famous passages in the
book is in Isaiah 52 through 53 which
again seems to be talking very clearly
about an individual servant how is this
one different in some way from the
others that we've looked at so far yeah
I don't think either one of us can
pretend to give a definitive
interpretation of this great fourth
servant song and Isaiah 52 and 53 people
have engaged this text ruminated on it
chewed on it for centuries it was big at
Qumran when we now know they looked at
it and applied it to their own situation
certain Testament certainly is the new
testament is all over it when the
Ethiopian eunuch is caught studying
Scripture in the book of Acts he's
puzzling over this chapter and just
wondering is this about something that
happened in the past is it about
something that was prophesied for the
far future how is it relevant to me
these are all our live questions in
terms of this passages relevance for for
now for us and how do we understand it
and I think one of the things that makes
this unique over against the other
servant songs that are in this material
is that there's all sorts of reactions
to the servant here there's Kings that
are so startled by him that they drop
their mouth
there's obviously a great mass of people
perhaps within the exilic community
itself that have a have totally wrong
impression of him they think that he's
suffering because God is judging him and
then there's the smaller group that
makes the startling confession perhaps
starting in verse four this smaller
group that recognizes that this
individual is completely innocent and
the horrible suffering that he's bearing
is a gift that he's making on their
behalf that actually changes everything
for them and they come into this new
relationship with him so on a number of
levels it's very special
so the it appears now not simply as
talked about the servant but from a
community that he experienced what
happened to this individual it has a
kind of personal quality about it and
the whole tone of the things you don't
usually get these first-person plural
confessions in the second Isaiah this is
very unusual and they seem to be talking
about a transformative moment yeah in
their own experiences yeah with this
individual yeah and in a way I get the
impression that this song is is meant to
explain how they reached conclusions
which we have in fact already seen
earlier in this literature yeah this is
finally the explanation for how they got
to the understanding that is now
expressed earlier in the second Isaiah
is that a fair way of thinking about I
think that's exactly right as a matter
of fact if you go back to the earlier
servant song in chapter 49 the group has
inserted verse 7 which is a
foreshadowing they're in chapter 49
verse 7 they're talking about how Kings
will just be blown away by what they see
when this servant suffers in this manner
so once this startling new realization
of the power of this servants ordeal
this servants bodily sacrifices is
realized I think it sheds new light on
the end
higher message that second Isaiah is is
conveying but I think you're absolutely
right when you talk about this new
relationship that that the we of the
poem has with the figure they start out
as the self-righteous stuck-up
individuals who who treat this servant
as a worm despised scum of the earth and
then they end up in this intimate
interconnection with him he bore our
griefs he carried our sorrows
so it's he us us they're they're coming
closer into interrelationship and as a
result suddenly they realize that
they're the sinful ones 4 6 we're all
like straying sheep we're all oriented
on our own direction we're following our
own lights we're not oriented at all on
God's transcendence or God's Word or
God's plan and suddenly that all changes
through this sacrifice and not only do
they understand in a different way now
the meaning of suffering they obviously
understand their own suffering in a
different way it's a it becomes a key
for the community to understand the
trauma that it has been through now
we've we have gotten some sense of that
in the earlier parts of second Isaiah
where they keep talking about the
community being weak the people who are
supposed to be proclaiming the result of
redemption of Zion are not really up to
the job there's been all this kind of
complaint about how it's just not
appropriate we can't do this just for
yesterday we were frail grass but
suddenly they understand that their own
feeling of inadequacy their own feeling
of weakness may be part of the suffering
that itself is going to become
transformative for the rest of not just
the community but for the rest of Israel
in the first instance yeah and this is
what we have been seeing probably
playing out in some of the earlier
material I had already suggested that in
chapter 40 the notion of the double
suffering of Zion is meant to be
understood in the light of this figure
and it seems to me probably what they
are doing here is almost unique in
Scripture the community is confessing
how it came to the understanding which
is now part of its own interpretation
yeah
and certainly the early Christian church
tapped into this big time that called
the Apostle Paul that he has
participated in the sufferings of Christ
and this is something that all disciples
in all communities of faith are expected
now to do it's a it's a peculiar type of
spiritual suffering that he's undergoing
it's it's a determined willed type of
suffering it's an it's an innocent type
of suffering it's the type of suffering
that non-violently
puts oneself in harm's way willing to
suffer blows and and strikes for the
sake of other people it's the type of
suffering that's pretty rare rare in our
world but the annoying thing about
Isaiah is that he thinks now this is
paradigmatic for the entire community
everybody now is expected to do this and
the community itself seems to recognize
in this figure the kind of suffering
that they have been undergoing and now
they understand it as part of their lot
as part of the people of God to do this
and to do it on behalf of the entire
community this is a very heavy
theological agenda that second Isaiah is
asking us as the most recent community
looking at this material is expecting us
somehow to take on I think the only way
the people today can even imagine doing
that is to capture something of God's
towering awesomeness if the world around
us the mundane banal reality that we
take so seriously is the the only world
there is this lifestyle is impossible
you really have to have a new vision
of God and the way that God's reality
renders our daily lives in some sense a
little bit less serious than we take
them in order for the student to work
itself out as long as this seems to deal
with the question of the role of the
community ultimately in Redemption and
one sort or another at the very end of
this section it brings up another
unresolved question that we have not
considered yet and that is the role of
the nations in this yes whether or not
the nations participate now we've
already looked at the nations in 2nd
Isaiah and their role is not very
pleasant
they undergo a massive judgment in 4 in
chapter 34 but the nations do come up
again after this great revelation of the
importance of redemptive suffering or
vicarious suffering that the group is
expected now somehow to participate in
having seen the example of this
individual so how does the fate of the
nations work at the end of this section
of second Isaiah yeah I think we're
focusing in on chapter 55 verses 3 to 5
essentially and there interestingly
enough we have reference to King David
who has not appeared in this corpus as a
matter of fact second Isaiah has been
loath to talk about David been
developing a sort of a different vision
of the remnant than the line of David
and yet here are this people this
remnant taking on the role of David as a
beacon or spiritual paradigm or signal
flag that the nation is sort of
gathering group around in verse 5 behold
this remnant will call a nation that you
don't know a nation which knows you not
will run to you because this majesty of
the Holy One has been gifted gifted to
the people
and this echoes the language again of
chapter 40 where the good news of the
people's return and of God's return to
Zion is first said to be for the benefit
of Israel the people are to go back
tsiyon is to give out the word to all
the cities of Judah that God has
returned this takes one step further
than that and can invite all of the
nations to participate in the redemptive
activity second I say it is not just a
message to one particular chosen no
second I Vegas God is just bigger than
that it's a it's a universal message
that reaches out I think so often
Christians think of the Old Testament is
so particular istic and so you know
narrow and chauvinistic and
nationalistic and that just doesn't fit
that doesn't work in this passage the
the ultimate beneficiaries of this are
the nations themselves and the group
itself which serves as God's redemptive
agents is responsible for that and now
in the very end of chapter 55 we get
another replay of chapter 40 where the
people were to come back God is leading
them back to the land to Zion
but now the inevitably fulfilled Word of
God has to do with the redemption of the
nation's you will go out in joy you will
be led back in peace again the notion of
the the whole cosmos working together to
facilitate this the mountains and the
hills before you will burst into song
all the trees of the field will clap
their hands instead of the thorn will
come up to cypress instead of the Brier
shall come up the myrtle and it shall be
to the Lord as a memorial has an
everlasting sign they promise that has
been given to Zion is going to be filled
it is an everlasting sign which shall
not be
cut off